bien vamos a empezar con una pequeña
prueba voy a presentarles ahorita una
imagen que tiene muchos puntos y lo que
ustedes tienen que hacer es tratar de
estimar cuántos puntos hay en esa imagen
no les va a dar tiempo de contar
simplemente traten de hacer una
estimación general listos
por favor levanten su mano quienes crean
que hay más de 80 puntos en esa imagen
levanten sus manos
que hay mantenga las levantadas no la
bajen con ustedes
son personas que pueden ser
categorizadas como sobre estimadores y
esto está asociado a una buena
característica
ustedes tienen la facilidad para
identificar el potencial en las demás
personas muchos estudios muestran esto
pueden ya bajar sus antes de bajar sus
manos duras a levantar y voltea a ver
volteen traten de voltear a ver en el
auditorio quiénes son ustedes que tienen
esta característica en común
bien pueden bajar las gracias
ahora vamos
con quienes vieron menos de 80 puntos
pueden levantar sus manos por favor
déjenla arriba ustedes pueden ser
considerados como o catalogados como sub
estimadores y esto también está asociado
a características positivas
ustedes tienen facilidad para
identificar situaciones de riesgo y esto
es también bastante importante en la
vida
entonces en este auditorio tenemos dos
tipos de personas sub estimadores y
sobre estimadores
bueno la verdad no la verdad todo lo que
acabo de decir está inventado nada de
esto está prueba no funciona para nada
supongo que algunos de ustedes si tienen
estos talentos pero no puedo saberlo yo
a través de esta prueba porque les acabo
de hacer esto
bueno acaban de ser víctimas de una
forma muy común de experimentación
social en la psicología que se conoce
como el paradigma de grupos mínimos esta
idea fue propuesta originalmente por un
psicólogo polaco en retail y la idea de
este de este tipo de experimentos
consiste en dividir a las personas en
dos grupos en base a una categoría
completamente arbitraria algo sin
sentido algo que es demasiado simple que
pensaríamos que no tiene ninguna
importancia y luego les das a las
personas la oportunidad de interactuar
entre sí consistentemente estos estudios
se encuentran
a pesar de que esta categoría no debería
de tener ninguna relevancia acaba
influyendo en la manera en que las
personas interactúan la gente usa esas
categorías para para navegar ese mundo
social use esas categorías para para
pensar quién con quién le conviene
juntarse y con quién no le conviene
juntarse tienen actitudes más favorables
hacia las personas que les fueron
asignadas esas categorías
esto puedes hacerlo estos estudios han
hecho cientos de veces en la psicología
se han hecho cientos de veces en la
psicología y puedes hacerlo con algo tan
sencillo como darle la mitad a la mitad
de un grupo camisas azules darle a la
otra mitad camisas rojas a uno de los
llamados rojos y a otros les llamas los
azules y solamente con eso puedes
empezar a observar estos efectos y esto
sirve para ilustrar el concepto del que
les quiero hablar hoy los seres humanos
somos criaturas tribales qué quiere
decir esto
los seres humanos navegamos el mundo
social buscando constantemente
identificar características que nos
permitan saber quiénes son nuestros
aliados quién es parte de nuestra tribu
y quién no pertenece a nuestra tribu
si no me creen piensen vean estos
ejemplos
vean estos ejemplos estas categorías y
cuando le ponemos la palabra me enfrente
a todas estas categorías mi género mi
partido político mi país mi familia
cuando le ponemos está cuando cuando
cuando lo experimentamos como una
categoría se convierte en una especie de
tribu en una tribu a la que yo le voy a
dar preferencia por encima de los demás
la psicología tribal tiene muchos
aspectos o está asociada a muchos
aspectos positivos por ejemplo nos hace
tener un sentido de pertenencia con el
grupo nos hace sentir tener un sentido
de identidad de autoestima de que somos
parte de algo genera cohesión entre los
grupos y esto puede servir para ayudar a
resolver problemas que enfrentamos en
común
y esto también nos ayuda también a
apoyarnos unos a otros hoy por ti mañana
por mí
y por último
nos ayuda también a tener un sentido de
trascendencia a creer que la vida es más
ahí que va más allá de mis propias
intenciones que soy parte de algo más
grande todos estos son aspectos
positivos de nuestra psicología tribal
pero también existe un lado oscuro
en el momento en que marcamos una
categoría entre quien pertenece a
nuestro grupo y quién no
ahí estamos marcando un límite que va a
ser una diferencia en cómo nos
relacionamos con las personas
a veces podemos tratar a quienes no
pertenecen a nuestra tribu con
indiferencia con antipatía incluso con
odio la historia de la humanidad está
llena de ejemplos terribles de como
estos mecanismos se pueden salir de
control
a veces también se manifiesta con una
lealtad excesiva sumisión completa a la
autoridad todo por encima el grupo por
encima de todo y muchas veces nos hace
perder la objetividad nos hace ser menos
inteligentes y nos impide tomar
decisiones racionales
estos mecanismos funcionaron muy bien
durante miles y miles de años en la
historia de evolución de los seres
humanos porque resulta ser que durante
miles y miles de años vivíamos en
pequeños grupos en pequeñas tribus de
ahí el nombre la psicología tribal sin
embargo esas características en los que
estos mecanismos evolucionaron no son
las características en las que vivimos
en la actualidad hoy en día vivimos en
sociedades extremadamente complejas
donde tenemos que interactuar con
extraños todo el tiempo con personas de
distintas tribus nosotros mismos somos
miembros de distintas identidades
tribales en distintos momentos de
nuestras de nuestro día y de nuestras
vidas
y algo está pasando en los últimos años
algo está pasando que cada vez más la
sociedad
parece estarse polarizando no solo en
términos políticos sino también está
permeando al ámbito social y esto puede
ser un problema gravísimo para el
funcionamiento de una sociedad
democrática de que depende de establecer
acuerdos que dependen de generar diálogo
entre los ciudadanos
quizá el ejemplo más importante de
polarización social que hay en la
actualidad lo vemos en eeuu y también es
donde tenemos más datos por ejemplo
fíjense lo que ha pasado en menos de 10
años entonces el porcentaje de personas
en eeuu que considera que no se puede
tener una relación de pareja con alguien
que vota por el otro partido hace hace 8
años en 2012 era de 33% ahora ha pasado
a ser del 55% cuando las personas en
eeuu se les pregunta si podrías te
gustaría o saldrías con alguien que
hubiera votado cuando los republicanos
les preguntan si si saldrían con alguien
que hubiera votado por hillary clinton
prácticamente la mitad dicen no hay
manera y en el caso de los demócratas el
70 por ciento dice que nunca saldría con
alguien que hubiera votado por trump
finalmente la estadística más las
personas que tienen hijos cuando les
preguntan si les gustaría os perdón si
les molestaría que sus hijos su hijo su
hija se casara con alguien de la tribu
política opuesta
esto en igual proporción republicanos y
demócratas casi cuatro de cada diez
personas dicen si me molestaría no
quiero que mi familia se asocie con otra
tribu
y estudios recientes han podido
demostrar como incluso la sociedad se
está fragmentando se está agregando en
cómo vivimos este estudio en eeuu hecho
recientemente hecho con 180 millones de
personas que es una locura para un
estudio publicar la revista han hecho
demuestra cómo vivimos ya cada vez más
en burbujas o al menos los
norteamericanos viven en burbujas donde
solo interactúan con personas que
piensan igual a ellos
no les puedo no puedo hacer suficiente
énfasis en lo grave que es esto para un
país democrático qué pasa con méxico
al final del día somos distintos a los
norteamericanos nosotros no tenemos este
sistema bipartidista y nuestra historia
también es diferente pero creo que es
innegable creo que la mayoría de ustedes
estaría de acuerdo conmigo en que algo
está pasando en los últimos años
este es un ejemplo
que ilustra cómo nos estamos dividiendo
como sociedad en esta encuesta de
mitofsky se le preguntó a la gente por
si aprueban el manejo de la pandemia del
presidente durante esta pandemia del del
cob y cuando las personas se identifican
como seguidores del presidente
prácticamente todos el 94 por ciento
dice si la prueba cuando las personas se
identifican como opositores del
presidente el 0 por ciento dice que lo
aprueba y lo mismo sucede no sólo con la
figura del presidente sino también con
quienes están asociados a su grupo
tribal a su tribu
hasta ahora hemos visto como estos
mecanismos tribales de la psicología
pueden llegar a dividirnos como sociedad
pero en este momento quiero hablar
también de cómo pueden hacernos menos
inteligentes pueden impedirnos pensar de
forma racional y objetiva
cuando estamos más preocupados por
pertenecer a una tribu a un grupo
literalmente nuestra capacidad de pensar
se va a ver nublada se ve obstaculizada
y quiero hablar de dos estudios
principalmente en este primer estudio
hecho por jeffrey coin lo que hicieron
fue lo siguiente invitan a estudiantes a
participar en estos estudiantes que
tienen ciertos tipos de ideología
política en eeuu esto es muy fácil
porque prácticamente no hay dos están
demócratas y estan republicanos y por
ejemplo llegan los estudiantes
demócratas al laboratorio y les
presentan una política pública no les
dicen a ver te va a pedir que leas esta
política pública y que merezca opinión y
resulta ser que esa política pública que
les dan a los demócratas estudiantes que
tiene estas creencias alineadas con con
los demócratas es una política pública
que haría perfectamente sentido que va
perfectamente alineada con los valores
de los demócratas
por ejemplo puede ser algo así como
aumentar los impuestos para redistribuir
más la riqueza
pero aquí lo que hacen estos
investigadores es darles claves sutiles
de que la propuesta viene por parte de
los republicanos y que tiene mucha
aprobación por parte de los republicanos
en el momento en que se introducen esas
claves que creen que hacen las personas
rechazan la propuesta en esto nos sirve
para nuestro país y lo mismo sucede con
los republicanos les ponen una política
pública que va alineada con sus
creencias a la mejor reducción de
impuestos
pero les dan a entender que la propuesta
viene por parte de uno
rey igualmente rechazan la propuesta una
propuesta que en principio va alineado
con lo que ellos consideran que es mejor
para el país
otro estudio que me gusta mucho por este
estudio hecho por x porque ya mis
colaboradores muestra como incluso
cuando estamos en esta mentalidad de
tribu podemos llegar a perder o se puede
ver obstaculizada en nuestra capacidad
de hacer los razonamientos matemáticos
fíjense lo que hacen en este estudio
primero les presentan a los
participantes no este es un tipo de
problema que les presenta que es un
problema que no tiene por qué despertar
esta psicología eléctrico es un problema
que no está politizado que no tiene que
ver con ningún problema social que que
polaricen
se trata de una crema que sirve para
quitar un sarpullido como ustedes pueden
ver allí en la imagen se muestra esta
matriz de datos
primero con las personas que usaron esta
nueva crema para tratar el sarpullido y
a cuántas personas se les mejoró el
sarpullido ya cuántas se les empeoró
en la parte de abajo son las personas
que no usaron la nueva crema estas
personas algunas mejoraron y otras
empeorar vean ustedes y piensen cual
quieren que sea la respuesta a este
problema
bueno pues resulta ser que muchas
personas tienen dificultad con este tipo
de problemas portal con tobey que la
matemática que hay ahí de por medio no
es tan compleja
estos problemas requieren una forma de
razonamiento cuantitativo que no a todo
el mundo se le da también pero en este
estudio se centran en justamente estos
estudiantes que pueden hacer muy bien
estos procesos y que dicen claro lo que
aquí tienes que hacer es comparar
primero el grupo de personas que usaron
la nueva crema y sacar la proporción del
total es decir sumar 223 unas 75 y sacas
qué proporción de los participantes
mejoraron
en este caso 75 por ciento y en el caso
de las personas que no usaron la crema
qué proporción mejoraron y que
proporciona empeoraron la proporción que
mejoró fue del 84% la crema no sirve no
no ponerse la crema te va a dar mejores
resultados entonces estos estudiantes
pueden hacer muy bien este análisis pero
luego les cambian la movida y les
presentan un problema que está
politizado un problema que va a
despertar esos estos instintos tribales
por ejemplo si eres demócrata te
presentan algo asigno ciudades que
prohibieron la posición de armas y
ciudades que no prohibieron la posición
de armas los datos son exactamente los
mismos y la solución es exactamente la
misma de acuerdo a los datos que están
como están presentados aquí las ciudades
que no prohibieron las armas son
ciudades
que tuvieron un es donde el crimen
disminuyó un 84% de ciudades mostraron
disminución en el crimen
entonces en teoría pues no hay que
prohibir las armas con estos datos que
son inventados
cuando si eres demócrata si eres
demócrata y te ponen ese problema
incluso aunque seas muy bueno con este
tipo de razonamiento cuantitativo te van
a fallar las matemáticas y vas a creer
que estos análisis
de hecho soportan tu posición política y
lo mismo pasa cuando él se invierte
cuando se invierte en los resultados en
los presentan a los republicanos pasa lo
mismo incluso interfiere con nuestra
capacidad de hacer análisis numéricos
eso nos lleva a hablar de qué tan
objetivos podemos hacer podemos ser a la
hora de evaluar situaciones que
justamente despiertan estos instintos
tribales y hay tan sólo algunos ejemplos
ha mejorado la corrupción a raíz de la
nueva administración bueno la respuesta
probablemente que vemos va a depender
muchísimo de si estamos con o en contra
de la nueva administración
si se propone un determinado programa de
becas de créditos de pensiones hoy te
especifican las características que
tiene esto será bueno no será bueno para
el país va a depender en buena medida de
lo que piensas a nivel político de quien
la está proponiendo el tema de las
manifestaciones del 8 y 9 de marzo
también
todos estos este tipo de temas
dependiendo de la fibra que toquen en tu
tribu pueden hacer que veas las cosas de
una manera o de otra
espero haberles convencido hasta ahora
que por más que muchas veces tenemos
convicciones que creemos que tenemos
absolutamente la razón
a veces puede ser que sí pero no
necesariamente estamos en lo correcto
hay veces que estos sesgos tribales
pueden nublar nuestro juicio como
entonces podemos mitigar los efectos de
este tribalismo político y social que
tiene efectos tan dañinos para las
sociedades democráticas
por un lado hay muchos de los psicólogos
sociales están decepcionados porque
tratan de hacer muchos experimentos y
proponer nuevas intervenciones y resulta
ser que las personas siguen a ferrari si
más es bien difícil apagar esto
pero hay ciertas cosas que podemos hacer
y creo que lo primero es reconocer
siempre que tengamos una discusión
siempre que estemos en un tema que puede
despertar estos instintos lo que tienes
que hacer es reconocer que no eres
infalible que tienes todos estos sesgos
y yo aquí lo que le recomendaría es lean
más sobre psicología política y sobre
psicología social aprendan más sobre
cómo funcionan estos sesgos van a ver
que es fascinante y te vas a dar cuenta
cuántas veces en tu vida la ha regado
porque precisamente por eso
2 trata de salir de tu tribu de confort
cuando como veíamos en esos datos de
segregación de cómo vivimos cada vez en
burbujas de gente que piensa igual a
nosotros se validan todos los que están
a tu alrededor validan claro que tú
tienes la razón por supuesto todos
pensamos igual trata de salir de tu
tribu de confort y métete a platicar a
hablar a discutir a dialogar con
personas que piensan distinto a ti
trata también de balancear tu dieta de
información lo mismo sucede todos los
medios de comunicación que consumimos
van muy alineados con las creencias
políticas y sociales que tenemos y claro
se siente padrísimo leer que se valide
todo lo que tú crees
sobre cómo funciona el mundo la política
la sociedad etc
trata de tener diálogos con personas que
piensan distinto de tener estos diálogos
y trata de que sean diálogos productivos
y para que puedan ser diálogos
productivos tienes que tratar de
reconocer que quién tienes enfrente no
es un enemigo no es una persona que
pertenece a otra tribu que esto es lo
que hacen estos instintos tienes que
tratar de verlo como un ser humano que a
la mejor compartes muchísimas cosas con
él o con ella
pero principalmente si quieres aprender
a nuevo nuevo y también si quieres
persuadir a alguien de que tú posiciones
es es mejor en una determinada en un
determinado problema tienes que tratar
de reconocer ambos tienen que tratar de
reconocer que tenemos estos sesgos
tribales y que tenemos que dejar de lado
y tal vez solo así con una curiosidad
genuina podemos llegar a interactuar
unos con otros no de esta forma tan
polarizada como lo estamos haciendo sino
de una manera mucho más productiva y
constructiva para una sociedad como la
nuestra
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]